PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Today
we're talking about
security, CDN, and BigQuery.
I am Priyanka Vergadia, and
welcome to This Week in Cloud,
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
In these virtual
times, everyone is
getting used to
the new technology
and working remotely.
That's why it's even more
important for companies
to look at a zero trust
model and the philosophies
of BeyondCorp.
Now we're working with
even more partners
to support devices,
networks, and just about
everything else to keep your
teams and organizations secure.
CDNs are vital for fast and
reliable content delivery.
And now, we're making Cloud
CDN easier and cheaper to use.
With an 80% reduction
on fetching content
from your origin and no
cache to cache field charges,
it's definitely
something you will
want to try out to improve
your app's performance.
Check out the updated
features and pricing details.
Throughout October and
November, Google Cloud
is offering no-cost
data analytics training.
No matter if you've just started
learning how to get insights
from your data or you
already have significant data
analytics experience, take
your skills to the next level
with this collection
of different training
opportunities.
Once you're ready, go for the
Google Cloud data engineering
certification to show off
your professional skills.
Migrating to the Cloud
is easy to talk about,
but getting started is
a whole different story.
That's why I've created
this collection of migration
strategies to help you plan
and walk through your Cloud
migration journey.
We've even put together
a one-on-one video series
to kickstart your migration.
So what are you waiting for?
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the links.
Any thoughts or ideas, leave
us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.